we're told that amanda read a report
saying that 49 of teachers in the united
states were members of a labor union she
wants to test whether this holds true
for teachers in her state so she is
going to take a random sample of these
teachers and see what percent of them
are members of a union
let p represent the proportion of
teachers in her state that are members
of a union
write an appropriate set of hypotheses
for her significance test so pause this
video and see if you can do that
all right now let's do it together so
what we want to do for this significance
test is set up a null hypothesis
and an alternative hypothesis
now your null hypothesis is the
hypothesis that hey there's no news here
it's what you would expect it to be and
so if you read a report saying that 49
of teachers in the united states were
members of labor unions well then it
would be reasonable to say that the the
null hypothesis the no news here is that
the same percentage of teachers in our
state are members of a labor union so
that percentage that proportion is p
so this would be the null hypothesis
that the proportion in her state is also
and now what would the alternative be
well the alternative is that the
proportion in her state is not 49 this
is the thing that hey there would be
news here there'd be something
interesting to report there's something
different about her state
and how would she use this well she
would take a sample of teachers in her
state figure out the sample proportion
figure out the probability of getting
that sample proportion if we were to
assume that the null hypothesis is true
if that probability is lower than a
threshold which she should have said
ahead of time her significance level
then she would reject the null
hypothesis which would suggest the
alternative let's do another example
here
according to a very large poll in 2015
about 90 percent of homes in california
had access to the internet
market researchers want to test if that
proportion is now higher so they take a
random sample of one thousand homes in
california and find that 920 or 92
percent of homes sampled have access to
the internet
let p represent the proportion of homes
in california that have access to the
internet
write an appropriate set of hypotheses
for their significance test so once
again pause this video and see if you
can figure it out
so once again we want to have a null
hypothesis and we want to have an
alternative hypothesis the null
hypothesis is that hey there's no news
here and so that would say that's kind
of the status quo that the proportion of
people who have internet is still the
same as the last study is still the same
at 90 percent or i could write 90
percent or i could write 0 point i could
write 0.9 right over here now some of
you might have been tempted to put 92
percent there but it's very important to
realize 92 percent is the sample
proportion that's the sample statistic
when we're writing these hypotheses this
is about these are hypotheses about the
true parameter what is the proportion of
the true proportion of homes in
california that now have the internet
and so this is about the true proportion
and so the alternative here is that it's
now greater than 90 or i could say it's
greater than 0.9 i could have written 90
or
0.9 here and so they really in this
question they wrote this to kind of
distract you to make you think oh maybe
i have to incorporate this in 92 somehow
and once again how will they use these
hypotheses well
they will take this sample in which they
got 92 percent of homes samples had
access to the internet so this right
over here is my sample proportion and
then they're going to figure out what's
the probability of getting this sample
proportion for this sample size if we
were to assume that the null hypothesis
is true
if this probability of getting this is
below thresholds below alpha below our
significance level then we'll reject the
null hypothesis which would suggest the
alternative